we have another chapter tonight in the
feud between two congresswomen one
republican who said something that even
her colleagues on her side of the aisle
have condemned and one democrat who's
reacting to those remarks and pushing
back
congressional correspondent chad pergram
tells us who's involved in what's being
said tonight good evening chad
good evening brett there was a call
today between the congresswoman it
lasted about two minutes it did not go
well
i will continue to fearlessly put
america first never sympathizing with
terrorists unfortunately ilhan can't say
the same thing and our country is worse
off for it
lauren beaubert said she wanted a
meeting but illon omar made it clear
that would not happen
both parties tell fox there were no
raised voices on the call bobert tells
fox omar hung up on her omar's office
says it was clear the call wasn't going
anywhere omar says bobert doubled down
on her remarks
mobert said she wants omar to apologize
for anti-semitic and anti-police
rhetoric omar's office tells fox the
minnesota democrat announced she was
ending the call
then hung up
this remark is what sparked the dispute
i look to my left and there she is
ilhan omar
and i said well
she doesn't have a backpack we should be
fine
bobert also referred to omar as a member
of the jihad squad on the house floor
earlier this month democratic leaders
demanded the gop quote take real action
to confront racism democrats have
tinkered with trying to censure bobert
and remove her from committees the house
already voted to strip republicans
marjorie taylor greene and paul gosar of
their committee assignments brett okay
we'll follow that congress is now back
from the thanksgiving break a ton to do
before the end of the year fund the
government build back better in the
senate where are we
well there is a singular must do for
this week fund the government by 11 59
59 pm eastern on friday this year in
rush is typical expect a band-aid bill
to avert a government shutdown it will
run through january the gop is pushing
for a longer bill through march raising
the debt ceiling is due by december 15th
and build back better maybe by christmas
and brett the senate just blocked
finishing debate on the annual defense
bill back to you
okay chad bergeron has us covered on the
hill chad thanks hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else